Ich bin auf der Sitzung Assistan Assit.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Sind Sie damit verstanden?
Ja klar, gerne.
Bevor wir über Beschwerden sprechen,
muss ich Sie um persönliche Daten bitten.
Zum Beispiel, wie heißen Sie?
Mein Name ist Thomas Müller.
Thomas Müller.
Könnten Sie Ihr Name und Nachname Buchstabieren?
Mein Nachname ist Müller.
M-U-L-L-E-R.
Mein Vorname ist T-H-O-M-A-S.
Danke schön, Herr Müller. Entschuldigung.
Wie heißen Sie?
Ich bin 40 Jahre alt.
40 Jahre alt? Okay.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Ich bin 15. Januar 1985 geboren.
15. Jahrzehnte.
Okay. Wissen Sie Ihre aktuelle Gebiet?
Ungefähr 60 bis 62 Kilogramm.
Entschuldigung?
60 bis 62 Kilogramm.
Okay.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
1 Meter 65.
Okay.
Nun können wir Ihre Beschwerden kommen.
Welche Beschwerden haben Sie?
Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen, Müller?
Ich bin schon seit ungefähr 5 Tagen Husten.
Und ich bekomme diesen Husten einfach nicht weg.
Sind die Husten dauerhaft oder anfahlartig?
Es ist immer dauerhaft.
Manchmal mehr, manchmal weniger.
Ja, auch hart.
Haben Sie trockene oder mit Auswurf Husten?
Trockene.
Trockene Husten?
Haben Sie bewusstzumessen oder Atemnot?
Ich habe Atemnot, wenn ich mich belaste.
Bei Belastung.
Träten Sie das Husten in besonderem Zeitraum innerhalb des Tages
oder nicht regelmäßig?
Immer wieder auch.
Wenn ich mich belaste noch mehr natürlich.
Aber auch in der Nacht, auch am Tag.
Okay.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Ich habe gestern gemessen, habe ich 38,5 Grad.
38,5 Grad.
Seit gestern haben Sie.
Ich habe gestern gemessen.
Vielleicht bis vorher auch schon gehabt.
Okay.
Also weich?
Vielleicht, ich weiss es nicht.
Wenn ich gemessen.
Haben Sie gemessen?
Ich habe gestern gemessen.
Ich habe gestern.
Okay.
Haben Sie stuflos, karchivis?
Nein.
Okay.
Haben Sie während besonders Husten Herzrasen, Herzklopfen oder Engelgefühl bemerkt?
Nein.
Momentan haben Sie Atemnot?
Wenn ich mich belaste.
Momentan aber nicht.
Nein.
Okay.
Haben Sie etwas bemerkt, dass die Schmerzen liegen oder verschlägt werden?
Ich habe keine Schmerzen.
Okay.
Entschuldigen, Husten?
Husten.
Zum Beispiel Ligen, Stegen?
Nein, habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Okay.
Haben Sie Ausluiza bemerkt?
Nein, habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Okay.
Haben Sie ferroha, ultimately berichten?
Nein.
Was haben Sie bemerkt?
Auf der Aussicht.
Nein.
Nein, hab ich nicht bemerkt.
Auf der Aussicht.
Entschuldigen, auf der Aussicht.
Okay.
Aber auch sehr höchstens haben sie keine andere Milchweine.
Ich bin sehr müde, sehr kaputt. Also ich bin sehr abgeschlagen.
Seit fünf Tagen?
Ja, zunehmend.
Tagend.
Ist das höchstens auch so genannt?
Ja.
Okay.
Und haben Sie in der letzten Seite ab oder zu gehen?
Hab ich nicht gemessen, weiß ich nicht.
Okay.
Gibt es in Ihrer Umgebung, gibt es jemand in Ihrer Umgebung, der in der Bescheidung haben?
Ja, hat.
Ist mir nicht aufgefallen, weiß ich nicht.
Okay.
Und wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Normal.
Okay.
Können Sie gut schlafen?
Ich haus das ja viel.
Okay.
Habt ihr das Problem, weiß ich nicht, oder mit dem Stuhlgang?
Nein.
Was?
Okay.
Sie haben wahrscheinlich keine Haarschmärzchen oder Gelenkeschmärzchen?
Ja, es sind keine wirklichen Schmerzen in den Gelenken.
Es ist eine Müdigkeit in der Abschlagenheit.
Aber richtigere Schmerzen habe ich nicht.
Okay.
Und leiden Sie an Corona nicht in der Krankenankung, Herr Müller?
Nein, ich habe keine Krankenkunden.
Und wahrscheinlich nehmen Sie keine regelmäßige Medikamente ein?
Ab und zu nehme ich meine Ibuprofen ein.
Ibuprofen.
Wo gehen Sie?
Ja, wenn ich Kopfschmerzen habe, oder wenn ich Schulterschmerzen habe,
oder Rückenschmerzen habe, dann nehme ich das ein.
Okay.
Meinen Sie, Muskelschmerzen?
Ja, Muskelgelenk.
Noch.
Okay.
Und wie viel Medikamente?
Wahrscheinlich 400 Milliliter.
Genau.
Okay.
Sind Sie schon einmal operiert worden?
Noch nie.
Ist Ihnen allergie bekannt?
Oder unverträglich bekannt?
Ich bin bekannt.
Okay.
Herr Müller, sind Sie gegen Kinderkrankheit verständig geimpft?
Nicht, eigentlich schon, ja.
Okay, super.
Waren Sie in der letzten Zeit, zum Beispiel in den sechs Monaten, ins Ausland?
Nein.
Okay.
Und wie ist Ihre Eltern?
Sind Sie noch gesund?
Ja, Sie haben schon Ihre Bewegung, Sie haben so einen Beschwerden.
Jetzt auch nicht mehr die Jüngsten.
Der eine hat, was am Herzen, mein Vater, meine Mutter, hat ein bisschen Zucker.
Zucker?
Alter Typ oder Junger Typ?
War auch keiner.
Okay.
Hat Zuckerkrankheit diagnostiziert?
Weiß ich nicht.
Schon länger oder?
Ja, ich denke schon mehrere Jahre jetzt.
Okay.
Wie alt ist Ihr?
Meine Mutter, die ist ungefähr 25 Jahre älter als ich, also ungefähr so 70 Jahre alt.
70 Jahre alt.
Okay.
Und Ihr Vater?
Ja, auch so.
Okay.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich habe ein Bruder.
Bruder.
Ist er auch gesund?
Ja.
Gesund.
Okay.
Hemmler, beim Schlafen, wie viele Kissen nutzen Sie beim Schlafen?
Eins.
Eins, okay.
Nutzen Sie mehr?
Nutzen Sie mehr, als Kissen?
Nein, nein, ein Kissen nutze ich auch.
Aber bei der manchen Erkrankungen, Krankheiten
nutzen die Patienten mehr Kissen.
Deswegen habe ich so gefragt.
Nein.
Sie haben wahrscheinlich kein Geschwisterbein bemerkt?
Okay.
Nein.
Was sind Sie vom Behuf?
Klimatechnik.
Ja.
Okay.
Sind Sie per Heilart?
Geziehde.
Okay.
Haben Sie Stress bei der private oder Arbeit?
Ah, Stress ist immer da. Stress immer immer.
Verruf nicht, nicht verruf nicht.
Okay.
Privat geht es mir gut.
Entschuldigung?
Verruf nicht, es ist immer viel zu tun.
Wollen Sie allein oder mit jemandem?
Ich lebe alleine.
Allein?
Haben Sie Kinder?
Nein.
Nein, keine Kinder.
Hemmler, nach uns sind Zigarette.
Ich raue nicht, nein.
Okay, trinken Sie Alkohol?
Am Wochenende.
Entschuldigung?
Welcher Typ trinken Sie?
Und die Dosierung?
Typ?
Bier, Wein.
Ja genau, so aus. Bier.
Aufsichtig.
Okay.
Wie viele Pfeile?
5, 6, 7, 8.
Kommt drauf an.
Wenn ich mich trinke, dann geht das schon mal ordentlich ran.
Aber es ist so viel.
Ich lege Ihnen für Ihre Gesundheit, Alkoholkonsum zu reduzieren.
Entschuldigung?
Wie viel darf ich trinken?
Weniger als 6, 7.
Wie viel denn? 5?
Ja, 1, 2 Fläche maximal.
Am Tag?
Nein, am Wochenende.
Woher?
Kommt mal mal.
Aber wenn Sie Hilfe brauchen, kann ich gerne Ihnen helfen.
Wie wollen Sie mir helfen?
Im Unser Krankenhaus gibt es Suchklinik.
Ich bin nicht süchtig.
Ich kann jederzeit aufhören, wenn ich möchte.
Nur am Wochenende.
Ich verstehe.
Ich muss noch eine Frage stellen.
Bitte nehmen Sie nicht persönlich, das ist eine Routinefrage.
Haben Sie Kontakt mit dem Droge?
Ich konsumiere Cannabis.
Seit wann?
Schon länger.
5, 6 Jahre.
Wie oft rauchen Sie?
Am Abend nehme ich schon einen.
Ich rauche Cannabis.
Ich konsumiere Cannabis.
Ich rauche keine Zigaretten.
Ja, ja.
Und rauchen Sie oder konsumieren Sie einmal pro Woche?
Alle 2 Tage.
2 Tage.
Herr Müller, wenn ich kurz zusammenfasse, Sie haben seit 5 Tagen trockenen Husten.
Bei Belastung leiden Sie unter Atemnot und Fieber bis 38,5.
Gestern haben Sie am Stehen gemessen und seit 5 Tagen Müdigkeit.
Sonst haben Sie noch andere Becher werden oder möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Nein, nicht mehr.
Ich habe meine alle Fragen gestartet.
Wenn Sie etwas hinzufügen, dann bin ich hier für Sie zur Verfügung.
Und wenn Sie fragen, kann ich Sie antworten.
Ist das wahrscheinlich auch noch eine Erkältung jetzt?
Ich muss noch ein bisschen nicht holen, dann wird es besser, dann nicht.
Ich habe auch viele andere Becher, die ich für Sie verwendet habe.
Ich habe auch viele andere Becher, die ich verwendet habe.
Und ich habe auch viele andere Becher, die ich verwendet habe.
Was ist das für Sie?
Ich habe viele andere Becher, die ich verwendet habe.
Nach der Ergebnisse können wir über richtige Diagnose sprechen.
Wichtige Diagnose?
Richtig.
Vermutlich etwas?
Wir haben hier noch das Aufnahmegespiel führen.
Aber die anämpfnistischen Angaben haben auf dem Aufbau der Lungenentzündung hin.
Ja, ich weiß, Sie haben keine Ausfuhr oder so etwas.
Aber manche Lungenentzündungen äußern sich so.
Aber nach der Ergebnisse können wir natürlich gerne sprechen.
Danke schön.
Gut, 17 Minuten.
Haben Kollegen oder Kollegen noch andere Fragen?
Übelkeit und Erwähnung habe ich nicht gepraktzt.
Bitte nicht sprechen.
Keine gute Frage.
Haben Sie keine?
Haben Kollegen Schulung besichert?
Nein.
Keine.
Haben Sie eine gute Frage?
Nein.
Sind Sie schon bei einem anderen Arzt gewesen?
Ich bin jetzt hier, weil Ostern alles ist zu.
Deswegen komme ich in die Notaufnahme.
Wurden Sie gegen Corona Impfung gelassen?
Ich wurde geimpft vor 5 Jahren oder 4 Jahren.
Corona Impfung?
Corona Impfung, ja.
Vor 4 Jahren.
Haben Sie nicht gesprochen?
Nein.
Ich habe keine Fragen.
Können wir erstens ein paar Fragen?
Ja.
Hallo, guten Tag Chef.
Ich bin der neue Arzt.
Ich habe einen neuen Patient aufgenommen.
Ich würde gerne Ihnen vorstellen.
Darf ich?
Gerne.
Herr Thomas Müller ist ein 40-jähriger Patient.
1,65 m groß.
60 kg schwer.
Er stellte sich heute seit 5 Tagen pro Grad.
1,65 m groß.
1,65 m.
bei der Belastung Atemnut vor. Der Patient gab an, dass er trockene Husten habe, sonst
die Fragen nach Auslöser und Auslöser wurden verneint.
Auslöser hat der Patient mitgeteilt, dass in seiner Umgebung
niemand in der Umgebung geblieben hat.
Der Patient klagt über auch öfter Erkartung. Leider der Patient unter FIBA bis 36,5, der Patient
gestern gemessen und vorher habe er FIBA aber nicht gemessen.
Beide vegetative Anemnese seien seit fünf Tagen bekannt und der Patient leide an keine
Erkrankungen. Bei der Schmerz sind 400 mg und bei der Erkrankung sind keine Erkrankungen
beides. Bei dem Patient ist keine Allergie oder Intoleranz bekannt. In der Familienanemnese
ist der Patient nicht geblieben und hat keine Kinder. Der Patient trinkt 5 bis 8 Bias am Wochenende
um 5 bis 6 Jahre mit Cannabis Kontakt unter den 2 Tagen Konsumieren der Patient.
Was haben Sie für eine Verdachtsdiagnose?
Die Anamnistischen Angaben deuten am 1. Auf Pynomonie in.
Seit 5 Tagen kosten mit FIBA bis 38,5. Sie sprechen für Pynomonie außer dem Düstne bei Belastung.
Könnte es nicht ein Gripala-Infekt sein?
Ja, es kann so sein, aber der Patient habe keine Halsschmerzen oder andere Beschwerden.
Was macht die Diagnose?
Die Diagnose ist die Erkrankung der Erkrankung der Erkrankungen.
Bei der Erkrankung der Erkrankungen ist die Erkrankung der Erkrankung der Erkrankungen
von der Erkrankung der Blutuntersuchung.
Bei der Erkrankung der Blutuntersuchung würde ich eine große Erkrankung der Erkrankung der Erkrankungen
der Erkrankung der Erkrankungen haben.
natürlich und gegebenenfalls provokalsutonin.
Danach lebanieren wir der Patient leider unter
Düstung, deswegen Blutgasanalyse ist ganz wichtig.
Und röntgen Torax werde ich bestellen
und gegebenenfalls Torax-Tomografie.
Was erwarten Sie, was kommt raus in Blutbilden und Röntgen?
Beide Röntgen kann ich Pneumotorax ausschließen und
eine Art Püchepinomene bestellen.
Aber manche Pneumonien oder Pneumotoraxen können nicht mit Röntgen
feststellen, deswegen gegebenenfalls Torax-Tomografie bestellen.
Was erwarten Sie im Labor?
Beide Labor warte ich natürlich in Zündung,
Parameter, Höheung und Locostos.
Wenn die Düstung schwer ist, warte ich auch bei der
Blutgasanalyse, Oxygen-Sauerstoff-Sätigung niedrig.
Eine leichte Hypoxie.
Wie würden Sie diesen Patienten therapieren?
Wenn mein Verdachtdiagnost bestellt ist, würde ich ambulante
Therapie empfehlen. Antibioterapie ist notwendig.
Symptomatische Therapie aus wichtig, der Patient habe,
Fiba, deswegen Antipyretik und
Antipyretik?
Um die atypische Bakterien, oder um die Bakterien würde ich
die Bakterien in den Klinien verschreiben.
Oder die Acetromis.
Acetrome 10 hört es gut an.
Man sollte dann Makrolyd und Pyrrhuschelyone einsetzen.
Was ist der Patient vom Beruf?
Das ist die Technik des Klinien.
Woran müssten Sie denken?
Die Legionelle Pynomene, die die Besonderstheorie
gebraucht hat.
Können Sie die Nachweisen, die Legionellen?
Ja, beide Arschstoffe können antigenen
feststellen.
Wo?
Urin.
Das ist ganz genau.
Können Sie schon in der Ambulanz machen?
Und ob der Patient zu Hause bleibt oder stationär bleibt,
woran halten Sie das fest?
Es hängt von Sauerstoffsetigung ab.
Bei der atypischen Prämonie haben die Patienten
sehr krank.
Aber die haben kein Ausruhr.
Aber sie haben eine große Infiltrate.
Und haben sehr hohe CHP.
Natürlich hängt auch Laborwerte ab.
Ganz genau.
Gut gemacht.
Vielen Dank für Ihre Bemögen.
Was sagen Sie?
Die Kollegin hat gesagt, Fatig.
Ja, Schöpfung, Müde.
Fatig ist fast eine Kollege, die uns gesagt hat.
Fatig ist eher bei Krebspatienten,
bei Paläthiebpatienten zum Beispiel.
Er ist eine kronische Müdigkeit.
Er ist eine neue Kollegen, eine neue Mitarbeiter.
Er hat gesagt, ich bin ein neuer Mitarbeiter.
Ja, richtig oder falsch?
Doch.
Aber Schöpfung muss wissen, wer Sie sind.
Aber vielleicht gibt es mehrere Schöpfungen.
Vielleicht ist es ein Honorarist.
Aber bei der FSB muss man nicht einen neuen Mitarbeiter.
Kennen Sie den Rega für atypische Prämonien?
Ja, legionale Prämonien sind besonders wichtig.
Ich kann nicht mit dem Rega sagen,
dass ich nicht mit dem Rega machen kann.
Ich kann nicht mit dem Rega sagen, dass ich nicht mit dem Rega mache.
Legionale Prämonien.
Ich muss nicht mit dem Rega sagen, dass ich nicht mit dem Rega mache.
Aber atypische Prämonien sind richtig wichtig.
Keine Immersion, keine Diabetes-Meditär, keine Alkoholabossus.
Ich muss fragen, Alkohol konzentriert am Wochenende, 5, 6 hier in Deutschland.
Und MRE ist eine Notfallarzt.
Warum fragen?
Deswegen habe ich gefragt.
Es ist nicht Ihr Problem.
Sie müssen sich auf das Krankheitsbild fokussieren.
Nebenbei ist es nicht notwendig.
Man kann es später machen.
Sie können nicht akut helfen.
Am Anfang war ich mir nicht sicher, ob der Fall Atypische Phänomenie ist.
Deswegen konnte ich nicht am Anfang gut Reaktionen gezogen.
Ich möchte etwas reagieren.
Sie haben schon gesagt, ich empfehle, weniger zu trinken.
Das sieht vielleicht aus.
Aber wenn der Patient fragt, wie viel ich trinken soll,
dann können Sie nicht sagen.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Ich würde mich auf die Hauptbeschwerden fokussieren.
Es sei, dass es etwas mit der Erkrankung zu tun hat.
Haben Sie noch andere Fragen?
Ich habe noch eine Frage.
Bei der Phänomenie sollten wir bestimmen, ob der Patient Konfusion hatte.
Wie können wir das abfragen?
Was?
Konfusion.
Verwirrung.
Das können Sie abfragen.
Sie können den Patienten neurolobisch untersuchen.
Sie können die Qualitäten beobachten.
Wer sind Sie?
Welche Jahreszeit oder Tatum haben wir?
Das können Sie in einer Nese fragen.
Wo arbeiten Sie?
Wo sind wir?
Sind wir in einer Schule?
Ist das hier ein Krankenhaus?
Oder ist es der Bürgermeister?
Wir haben Winter.
Welche Jahreszeit haben wir?
Welche Tatum haben wir?
Das können Sie schon abfragen.
Wenn der Patient verwirrt, antwortet, das merken Sie.
Meistens kommen die bewirrten Patienten nicht selber.
Jemand bringt sie ins Krankenhaus.
Sie kommen mit Begleitpersonen.
Die sagen meistens, ich habe Ihnen den Herrn Schmidt mitgebracht.
Das ist der Herr Schmidt.
Wir haben die